foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the dreams
turned out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
myself
Our Stars
[Music]
down
[Applause]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what's up
when I am
today please
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
some days
[Applause]
[Music]
I live around
us
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the teeth
together
because
[Applause]
[Music]
days
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
because
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
five people
[Music]
oh my baby
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God foreign
foreign
[Music]
shares
to me please
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
questions
[Music]
my shirts everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
together
my chance
[Music]
tell me
please
[Music]
foreign
Lucy to our final resting place
and the family to our Korea
rented their garments
because the children have to render
their garments
for their mother
foreign
minimum
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Mommy
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
champion
foreign
[Music]
thank you
bye
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
shut up
foreign
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
hold on
you believe in me it's my favorite book
no matter what you would read to me I
look forward to taking out all the books
but for the grandchildren
um
foreign
[Music]
small was one of the children it was a
fox and big was the month box
small said but what about when you're
dead and gone would you still love me
just love going because I've gone
large house small snug and he looked out
at night at the moon in the dark and the
stars shining bright small look at the
sky how they shine and glow yeah some of
those stars died long ago so they shine
in the evening Skies love like
Starlights
attention
is
foreign
thank you
dear friends and family and everyone
else who has come here
to show their support of our family
I and my sisters parents and family are
truly touched by the outpouring of
emotion and solidarity shown by all of
you who are here today and who have
blind the streets all the way here
and to send messages of support and
kindness
my dear sister lucianne known to most as
Lucy
came from a reasonably ordinary English
family but she was No Ordinary Girl
our family lived on the outskirts of
London and Lucy went to the local state
school walking just a few blocks each
day to school like many many other kids
in England
we all went on ordinary bucket and Spade
holidays to the same Resort in Italy
each year and then later to the same
place in France
she loved marmite
City
and playing tennis
she loved competing in games with me and
her sisters and nagging our parents for
sweet and treats like any other normal
trials she loved hiking gardening and
flowers
but Lucy was No Ordinary Girl
she had a radiant smile and she had a
fire within her that burned strong and
when she set her mind to it she was
magnificent
she decided to learn Japanese and then
set her sights on Oxford University
and she achieved both of those goals
the family was not particularly
observant but she decided she wanted to
become more religious Jew so she
encouraged us to all follow her moral
values and practices
and she set her heart on Leo
and they were the perfect couple
but although Lucy Had A Fire Within her
to achieve the goals she wanted she also
had a heart of gold
with her degree from Oxford she could
have chosen a root focus on materialism
and wealth
but she saw a world around her where she
could make a difference in other ways
Lucy started by organizing educational
events in the London area of St John's
wood with passion and enthusiasm
but then she she and Leo turn themselves
full time towards fostering a sense of
togetherness in the community first
intended a suburb of London
however the Lucy and Leo team really
came into their own when they moved to
radlett where they nurtured a community
Spirit very successfully for a number of
years
reinvigorating the village and leaving a
lasting Legacy
despite their success in radlett Lucy
and Leo felt they wanted to bring their
children up in a more communally minded
way than any Village in England could
offer
so they immigrated to Israel so the
wonderful community of Efrat
where people all rally round to help
each other
crime is virtually non-existent and
there is a real Community spirit
and then Lucy chose to give back to the
community in the way that she felt she
could best
by teaching English to those Israelis
who wanted to improve their skills
mentoring and cooking for those as
mothers of new babies and volunteers
Lucy was also a caring devoted mother to
her five beautiful children
and brought them up that they they were
kind
compassionate and empathetic and could
take their place to improve the society
around them
to those who she befriended Lucy was
kind hospitable and considerate and only
wanted to help make the world a better
place
unfortunately
Lucy has been cruelly taken from us far
too soon
about her Legacy and that's admire and
Rina of kindness
and doing their bits however small to
make the world a better place
will live on in all of us to also try to
when you do acts of kindness remember
Lucy Maya and Rina
and think of all the kindness in this
world and how we can all still do our
bit to make the world a better place
the scientists say that in the Merit of
righteous women our ancestors our
ancestors were redeemed from Egypt and
in the Merit of righteous women the
future Redemption will come about
I believe Lucy was one of those nashim
Sid kaniot righteous women
and in the Merit of the life she lived
and the Legacy she lives we are closer
to our ultimate goal
Gabi
Orchestra
it's impossible to put into words how
much my sister meant to me and how much
I loved her and it's very hard to speak
here today
but my sister Lucian okay she's my
sister's first step and I called her was
the strongest person that I knew
she handed her strength onto her family
and so we are all jewelry on that
strength now
Lucian wasn't just a sister
she was also my best friend
and a loving mother to my sister Steph
and me throughout our childhood to the
present day
even though we lived in different
countries I knew pretty much every
aspect of her life if something bad
happened I'd call Lucia if something
good happens I truly said and if nothing
was happening at all of course yeah
thank you
she was always there for me
she used to impart Pearls of Wisdom
practically every time that I spoke to
her without me even knowing it
when the family in London experienced a
difficult time recently she got straight
to the plane and stayed with my family
and then with Jess
she provided support and love to all of
us wearing her sparkling earrings and
colorful scarves
she spent her life giving to everyone
and sharing her values of kindness and
compassion
she and Leo built the most amazing
family and life first in London and then
in Israel
she loved her face
she loves her family
Leo
Maya Karen Sally Rina and your Hooda
meant everything to her
she was a phenomenal mother an
inspiration to us all
we will all miss her but she has taught
us to be strong and how to carry on
thank you to everyone for supporting all
of us as we tried to carry on
hours
benjamination Stephanie
I'm speaking for Stephanie our other
sister who is heavily pregnant and I've
been advised not to come to the funeral
where to start
lucianne was the best sister anyone
could ask for despite living in
difficult different continents
she made sure that we were in regular
contact
lucianne would call me every Friday to
find out about my week my kids my
cooking
she was never interested in talking
about herself only about others
if I was ever upset about something she
was there and she would listen
Lucian grew up in Hampstead Garden
suburb
she looked after and helped care for me
and Gabby as we grew up
being incredibly smart lucianne went to
Oxford University
she learned Japanese in Japan
and she kept kosher there which was no
easy feat
whilst the doctor said she met Leo
it was at the ballroom dancing
competition
Leo and Lucy got married then went off
traveling around the world visiting
farfan flung places
they lived and worked in Australia they
came back to the UK and had Maya and
Karen they moved to ephrat and
essentially never looked back
Lucian was so happy in a frat where she
felt at home and at peace
for Lucian family was everything
and if that was the ideal the perfect
place in which her children could grow
up
in a frat Lucian and Leo instilled the
best possible Jewish values in their
children
loving kindness putting others before
yourself charity and respect these
values will forever live on in Karen
tally and Yehuda foreign
I want to end my note with a few silly
but special memories of my sister
Lucian could go to sleep on air of
Shabbat with her makeup on and wake up
on Shabbat morning with her face still
looking perfect
lucianne believed that any plain T-shirt
or jumper could and should be jazzed up
simply by the addition of accessories
Lucian was passionate about vegetables
and always tried to make me eat greener
her latest attempt was kale
by midday on a Friday lucianne would
have made food for the whole of Shabbat
including separate catering for the
vegetarians pescetarians and meat eaters
in the house
finally during lucian's Last Visit to
London during which she stayed with my
family she gave us a gratitude book
the idea being that in it we would each
write a daily message of gratitude and
thanks about each other
Lucian wanted us to take each other for
Grant not to take each other for granted
and to be thankful for every single day
I will try to live out this message and
countless more talk to me by my darling
sister every day in her memory
what do you got there front
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
local
[Music]
thank you
Leo the product is
requested to join in the following
words
[Music]
repeat after
I will pray
[Music]
foreign
Lucy
you wanted me to make you a special
speech in your 50th birthday
and now this
Lucy you were a great companion for
everyone
but for me you were my best friend
we were each others
we literally traveled the world together
we met Aliyah together we built a new
life for ourselves in the Promised Land
you would frequently say
that you couldn't imagine living
anywhere else
nor could I
even now especially now
where the war Embrace we found for the
people of a frat from guccion from
Israel and worldwide
during covid we spent so much time
together enjoying the lockdowns we would
sneak down the 60 Highway which was
completely empty and head off to the
Dead Sea where we hiked every riverbed
following the advice of hiking in the
Holy Land
that was your passion Lucy and you made
it mine
so much so that for my 50th birthday
last year you took me to the lower
larger walk with a 13 meter rope
climbing down 20 dangerous waterfalls in
March 2022.
that damn Dodger there was a group of
fifth Israeli soldiers and us you were
proud of the achievement that swore you
would never do it again
Lucy you'll never be doing that again
in any case when Kobe ended we made a
decision
we would reduce our working week to four
days
and go hiking on Thursdays with one
another
and so we did every week for the last
two and a half years
recently I started feeling a little
guilty for having so much time off
and would work and do a good couple of
hours of maths class preparation in the
afternoons
now I wish I'd take it every Sunday
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday as well
you were so generous
you trained to be a new mother counselor
and visited a new mother baby we clean a
frat to give her support
you mentored a new teacher in Jerusalem
zooming him weekly sometimes two or
three times to help him get the ropes
you organized the Shabbat shield for
women in our neighborhood finding
speakers and locations
and frequently in our home thank you we
spent six years as a rabbitical couple
in Hendon and radlett from 2004 to
2000 2008 to 2014.
those were wonderful years that we also
had much time for one another
and I say rabbinical couple because you
were the main event and I was just
occasional speaker
you brought people together in our home
arranging social events or festivals
bouncy castles for the kids on Haruka
bringing 20 people around our shop at
table most weeks and I just made the odd
surname
and talking about Shabbat meals
your Friday night chicken soup recipe
was a secret from me I was allowed to
help on any discs except that
then last Shabbat you're making you're
marking National English oral
proficiency tests and we were so busy
that you WhatsApp me the recipe and said
make it
now I don't have to make the chicken
soup alone but at least it will be yours
you're an amazing mother you described
yourself as a CEO of the family and me
as the CEO
the kids had to participate in the Home
Laundry cooking washing up
you would tell me what you wanted the
kids to do and I would be the one to
manage them that way you thought they
would resent me and not you for making
them work
the problem was that they knew that I
didn't have a clue what needed to be
done and so the tasks ultimately had to
come from you
you thought that this would make the
kids lovely Less on the contrary Lucy
because you got that to help they loved
you more
at the hospital yesterday I saw a young
couple with a few young children at the
top of the escalators
that will give you a little annoyed with
the children who are arguing with one
another
I wanted to tell them to enjoy every
minute because you never know what
tomorrow will bring
[Music]
you're an excellent English teacher as
of Elias just told us
you began your training when we arrived
back from in 2014
and you worked while you left
you started off in some difficult
schools and with some difficult students
and at times I wanted to tell you just
to quit
then you found your pace
you clicked into the work and became the
most inspiring of teachers
you use technology you play games you
engage the kids you inspired me to take
up teaching and probably many others you
are magnetic
you believe the shortage of English
teachers in Israel at the moment was a
perfect opportunity for anglos to make
Aliyah
today I understand you can start
teaching English and learning to teach
English at the same time getting a
decent salary from day one
you dreamed that there would be a wave
of English Jews coming to live in Israel
including our families
Lucy you cared about all about all of us
writing special notes for US baking
gluten-free cakes for me and making
delicious vegetarian food for tally
veggie lasagna veggie meatballs and rice
and we would come home from a day's work
or at school or from school and find it
sitting on the counter with a little
note explaining how to heat it up
Lucy I don't think I would have said
this at your 50th but I think it's
appropriate now
you approved yourself throughout your
life
I fell in love with you during a tickle
nail salon an all-night learning program
that you put together at Oxford
University Jewish Society
the rabbi had canceled at the last
minute and you stepped up to arrange the
students to speak from 10 pm through to
5 A.M
you said you fell in love with me
because the speakers usually only had 20
minutes content for each hour slot but I
asked so many questions that it dragged
on for an hour
the next day you were out at my friend's
room to play bridge
two of us were pictured against two
masked PhD students we won
I overbid you under bid and together we
somehow got it right
after 24 hours I came back to London and
told my elderly grandmother that I met
the girl I was going to marry
then you were 21 and I was 23. but you
spent a year in Japan so it took more
than it took two more years to happen
since then Lucy I admit I've continued
to overbid
I was the one who stopping sure I was
one who spoke I got the glory even today
you continue to underbid you were the
one who did all the hard work
modestly I've got less Acclaim like
today
but the strength for everything I did in
my life came from you from where will I
get that strength now
your favorite programs that we watched
on the computer in bed at night were
Bake Off MasterChef
Pottery throw down and the sewing bee
it's all about people doing things that
they were passionate about and doing
them extremely well
we both love the passion that amateurs
had for their Hobbies cooking Pottery
sewing
and when you see someone with passion
their enthus and rub their enthusiasm
rubs off on you
in the words of our sages what comes
from the heart speaks to the heart
and you were so passionate about Maya
Karen Tali Rita and Yehuda Have you
shared your passions with them your
passion for life is rubbed off on them
and that will be one of the major
factors pulling us through all of this
in the son of songs we read on Shabbat
the lava is trying to contact his bride
and he knocks on her door
[Music]
she really wants to greet him but it
takes the time to organize herself and
by the time she gets to the door he's
left
she thinks that he thinks that she no
longer loves him
but Lucy I will continue to knock and to
wait and I will never take your absence
as a sign that I love and burnt out
in the Asia trial
that we sing every Friday night around
our table and we sang by your bedside
together yesterday afternoon
it states
have children rise reclaim her and her
husband Praises her
Lucy I'm so sorry that in your lifetime
we didn't say these things you wouldn't
even have allowed us to why did it take
until now for us to praise you
thank you
you were airlifted from the medicine
I can't imagine the pain physical and
mental if you were conscious in any way
for that Journey
on Sunday I talked about looking at the
good
Lucy I have a choice
I could to amend over the next 25 years
of marriage that I've lost
but I actually feel blessed to have had
25 years of a beautiful marriage with
you
by Friday your life was at its peak
it really goes in your seven apps in
order those being friends Family Fitness
from kite function finances and Flame
when we occasionally had an evening out
for dinner together
we would go through them all each of us
separately one by one and score how our
life was progressing against these seven
important dimensions
we knew that we could never have all
seven perfect at once
since spending time with family means
spending less time with friends and
spending more time at work means
spending less having less time to one
another
but precisely last week you seemed a
complete balance for the first time not
me but you bizarre
non-jewish friends of mine have asked
why you put simple stones on the grave
when we visit
and not expensive flowers
I don't know the official answer but my
father gave me some of his wisdom ones
and it seems to be spot on
he told me you have to treat somebody
well while they're alive so that when
they're no longer here you feel no
regrets you mustn't feel I wish I just
told her I wish I'd just done that
if so you don't need expensive flowers
on the grave spend the money on someone
who's alive give it to charity the stone
is enough to show you care Lucy I know
you know I love you I know you know we
all love you Stones today will be enough
you didn't always like your Hebrew name
left
Leia was the less loved wife of Jacob he
preferred Rachelle
why did you have to be named after the
second best
but then he realized with the Joseph
thing and all that preferential
treatment of one of Rachel's Sons
Jacob and Rachel cause much animosity
amongst the family
Leia was far more even-handed with her
kids and they all felt a lot equally
the Messiah will come from the tribe of
Judah Leia's son not from Rachel
and one thing more Leia who is second
best in her lifetime was buried in the
double grave with Jacob in our holy city
of Hebron not Rachel
and our double gray will soon be half
full next to the girls just 50 years too
early
Lucy did we fight
sure we thought
and in front of the kids you felt that
was good that they should love it in a
relationship
is natural it's part of growing together
God forbid the children should marry and
break up after the first major arguments
because they felt it wasn't working
we always try to keep the rules of the
talmud however and make up before we
went to sleep at night the logic being
the people used to die in their sleep so
make up while you can
I'd say the night
I quoted David sacks previously
scriptwriter for The Simpsons now
inspiring baltusuba and people of the
late Rabbi shrimo kalbach from his
Spotify bro podcast with his excellent
command of English
how we use many
miswords we misuse many words in our
speech
we say I need a new car I need a new
dress I need a new phone
but he also think about what we have I
have a close family I have a loving wife
I have a warm community
and then he says
change the word have for the word need
and the word need for the word want
I want a new dress I don't really need
it
I want a new phone I don't need it
and likewise
I need a close family
the things that I have I need I need a
warm Community what we have is what we
need
what we say we need is what we want
so Lucy I need you back
translates to Lucy I want you back
and I have very beautiful children
translates to I need three beautiful
children
it sounds like a small change
but it really helps when you can't sleep
at night
I'm learning from this appreciate what
you have now you can never assume it
will be there tomorrow
Lucy had another little discussion topic
which we would regularly bring up at the
Shabbat table when the kids were younger
we should have continued it many more
years
the late chief Rabbi Lord Johnson sacks
once instructed us to ask three
questions Around The Family Table
what did you do for someone today
what did someone do for you today and
what did Hashem do for you today
try it it's amazing it forces you to
think about the important things in life
and not the day-to-day stuff
what Rabbi sax calls eulogy values not
the resume values
well what did I do for someone today
Lucy I'm eulogizing you
what did someone do for me today the
list is too long but thank you to all of
you who have been there for us
what did Hashem do for me today he
brought us to live in Israel to make our
lives here he gave us all of you the
Jewish people and many non-jewish people
that come out and forced to support us
at this time
Tanya
he's a very good friend
of Lucy
an example to all of us
but kogan struck she had to quit her job
as a Dutch speaking tour guide decided
to volunteer 40 to 80 hours a week for
mother the Israeli Ambulance Service as
a driver
she was out income last night and she
posted me this message that she wanted
me to read out
these are her words
I hope it's okay I'm writing I don't
know who else to tell
the birthing rooms on a ship we have no
magazine
they are all in surgeries
bringing life to people who will please
God make long healthy lives thanks to
Lucy and Leo and the Beautiful Brave
family
I've been crying on and off since I came
to work
but I'm not useless I have power
to help the women in pain cope
to pray for the women of Israel
for the mothers and the fathers and the
sisters and the brothers and the friends
who need hashem's help more than ever
for all of I'm Israel to bring us back
to not feel lost to feel hashem's power
and admit we are powerless to control it
all and to give it up to him with love
and Hope and Faith for this I Pray
tonight
no anesthetists
thank you to everyone who's pouring in
love these day if nothing else was
tremendous Comfort to us when I woke up
in the middle of the night multiple
times and checked my Facebook with so
many smiley faces with Israeli flags
from all over the world
mayor of Vivi
the Frat that you've helped to create
is providing us with Incredible strength
when we left our home and traveled
through the streets of a frat and had
literally thousands of people waving
flags as we passed by we felt like a
royal family at the coronation but then
we realized
that no Goyle family would ever get such
a warm greeting
the flag social media post has been a
way of enabling thousands of those
outside of frat to get a small feel of
the level of warmth that we have had
inside our small but Grand community
we are blessedly part of the city we are
blessed to be part of amisrael we're
blessed be part of humanity that's
beginning to wake up and recognize its
soul
thank you for pouring in your love
I never was that sort of person
Lucy was
I don't deserve it but she does
maybe I'm just getting all of this in
her Merit
Yehuda said yesterday
that we should never ask llama why
but we should ask Lamar for what reason
what do we do about it
today we can possibly see what we can do
but we can never say why us why Lucy why
Arena why Maya
but we may answer possibly why now
because this week is the week of leaving
slavery and learning to be free
had this event has this event Unleashed
a power is a relative power in humanity
that transcends the borders of old
country's religion and politics
in an era where truth is defined by the
number of likes is there a higher truth
something that we can all sense
where were you born with a moral and
obligational system built in but just
never knew how to use it
could have been there's a new awareness
going against humanity that we are all
connected
could it be that we all came from the
same spot that we all had the same
moment of creation that we are all one
is there a higher truth than the one
we've read in our
algorithmically generated news feeds
could the timeless knowledge of our
ancestors still have something to teach
us
so many thousands of years later
were there things that they knew and
we've forgotten but now need to be
reminded of
thousands of people have contacted me in
the past few days and I thank you all
but if people have time to contact me in
their busy schedules
then how many of us also have the time
to do one more thing for someone else
who's alive and who would appreciate it
even more
I want to conclude
you've been here long enough
I wondered if I would ask Lucy to make a
blessing for all of us
what she might say
number one forgive
when you hold grudges it only hurts you
number two
apologize
even if it's not your fault
maybe it appeared to be your fault and
if that's all it takes so why not
number three
don't get upset for too long Robert
Goldberg I quoted uh two days ago
calls it five for five if in five years
time it's not going to be a big deal
that doesn't deserve more than five
minutes of your time today
number four
be passionate about what you do
if not change what you do
the first commandment is
get out of bed in the morning like a
lion
and I always wondered how can you do
that surely can't be commanded to jump
out of bed in the morning just just to
do that if you don't want to jump out of
bed
um you won't
I think what it means is find yourself
an occupation an activity that you're so
passionate about
that you want to jump out of bed in the
morning
number six you don't have to be the best
you have to give it your best
number seven explore
grow older if you're so fortunate but
never grow up there should always be a
Wonder in everything
number eight love all your children
equally we learned this from Leia
and then in the words of a late chief
Rabbi love is something that is not a
zero-sum game
the more you share the more you have
Lucy you shared your love
and you created so much love in exchange
nothing will ever replace you
your soul is part of my soul
your lessons live on in Karen tally and
Yehuda and in me
your life has traveled across all of
humanity in an instant
you held on so we could honor you
individually and give you a unique
send-off for a unique soul
a soul that has changed and will
continue to change so many lives
may your soul be bound up in the bond of
everlasting life things but that's what
happens
thank you
number four
minutes
all right
foreign
my life
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
but she needs a haircut but she needs
is it coming this way
taco
[Music]
yesterday
oh my God foreign
[Music]
thank you